finish over the outstretched from the
gig big time
there's Caruso's ability can shoot it
the pastor he finds Anthony Davis the
Lakers of the four-point lead Davis
leading with 10 player was terrific
there's his passing ability right there
he shoots that's being led by Spencer
did what he he's got 20 15 Victorian
Prince as Avery Bradley connects there
to give the Lakers of five-point lead
hinson gliding but Caruso got the best
of him finds himself on the floor he
might be hurt nobody's sitting because
of a blowout here's Graham
[Applause]
I said leave his way through traffic who
wants it who's got it he'll take it now
it's dandy good he's gonna hit the first
one Danny Green great crew here at
Staples Center Bryan's along Savita
[Applause]
James got it out to caldwell-pope Alex
Caruso is more athletic than you think
and he worked hard on his body goes to
the rim with authority and leaves no
doubt
mr. cleaver might have been better
served to step to the left Belinelli
will be in in a moment
Caruso high off the window higher and it
goes over the backboard the touch our
Coors refreshing life show here look at
the Caruso shot high off the glass if it
goes any higher
great job by cool so they tried a
dribble handoff and he did a great job
of getting his left foot over the top so
that he could get a hand on the ball
shields off Zach Lavine gets the foul
the basket and one and we talked about
how long for Anthony Davis
he's back kuzmic it's a very much
deserved rest
with six to shoot where to shoot now
for the Saab dump got into the middle
via the drill stop the clock getting the
ball into the middle Caruso dribbles
into the middle and gets an easy assist
when that last play to Anthony day look
at the dive by Caruso and the finishes
Jim Johnston gets out of the way I don't
want a piece of that one ooh I'm not on
any poster tonight but right now is the
lake of this imposing their will on the
offensive end re Spellman is back in a
stolen bike Caruso
Kuzma
play golf been cheated on the floor and
alex caruso
crusoe makes a move all the way
beautiful landed that quick reaction by
kuru salute the steel Caruso with the
steel on the full court pressure
now they bounce so Alex reverse lab for
he gets rewarded doesn't he player the
league
[Applause]
[Applause]
technical file for 2010 like he was
going to Rondo won that play did a great
job of looking off to the fitter but all
of a sudden Caruso is available open
path for the rim the delivery by Davis
and the Finnish vodka Russo and just
like that the Lakers go back up by tears
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this shot by Danny Green Dwight thinks
he's got it off has a rebound all of a
sudden here comes Caruso nobody put a
body on him and he put a highlight way
up into the stands here
[Applause]
for the top third another look at Caruso
going to the rim easily washing in is it
Davis is I'm searching out Kyle Cruz
mutters its prior to workouts in doing
some three-point shooting with one of
the best ever part of me Kyle Korver as
Alex Caruso finishes the lay head him in
a real nice vise try to attack please
look good defense by Cruz they deny at
the rim now Alex German can just flat
shoot the ball he's gonna die this time
but the Lakers bottle him up and steal
it again
it's go CP riding it all the way for to
this year
it's pretty impressive in the short
clock Caruso were two
15th in a row on the road gonna be tough
tonight
Caruso it goes Caruso much-needed who
started and who says I better go to work
or go to work he does lose one return in
one hand flow doing hits the basket and
the foul a cutter to Crusoe basket after
to steal Caruso drains the triple
[Applause]
put roots out let's play defensively a
great job of reading Network which is
open again I've said it before he's a
combination of Larry Bird and Magic
Johnson he's a he's an outstanding
player and he's competent and caruso
driving
quarter defensively
[Applause]
reject it for the Lakers I just like the
way they play team ball Anthony David
just cooking dinner next trip down
Anthony from the Blind Side
yet another block so Lakers making them
pay the block the starts tiss Dwight
says wait till you shoot it then I'll go
up see the ball block the shot and then
Caruso the touch foul now up 85-79 so
nice spurt here
[Applause]
timeout this team turned it over by
Drummond and look at the Lakers go
[Applause]
Lakers go up 88-79 just in the NBA in
free-throw percentage last heading in to
the second quarter only getting better
legitimate score without running
anything for the upside people in LA
absolutely adore Caruso he gets MVP
chance a bull figure points and eight
straight for the rookie Darius garlic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
slammed white turns the corner and then
look at white hesitating just wait Pam
throw it down that's the easiest hoop
you can get into half-court set well as
Mike was talking about right at the top
down he's got a shot blocker but I tell
you he's a good position
this to go it's a got his shot blocked
but then he reaches in from out of
bounds when he reaches it there's the
elbow right on the nose that ball goes
right to dry for the easy basket Larusso
nice pass inside apparently what a
beautiful look with his offhand Fork
muskets inside it floats it up for the
rebound Neto stolen by Caruso Nano in
pursuit
lays it up and in won't visit here in
the regular season
dangerous pass Caruso deflects it James
right back to Caruso back to James and
it's an eight-point game great
anticipation and then vision and again
you're not finding this type of tenacity
athleticism and vision at the park well
Frank Vogel's each double-team cutting
his perucho he's in deep glass to go up
and under we're passing a tie for
with it score Wow and the Caruso gets it
back gets the foul it gets the basket
three-point opportunity I know about
Monte Morris at Iowa State his character
is as steady as his handle oh no
question right time guys Alex Caruso
with a good finish 14 9 in this quarter
so yeah they were doing a good job
Denver bench 7 of 10 from the floor
Anthony Davis gets the basket there
[Music]
[Applause]
benefited from not being called but it
looked like Caruso got fouled at
midcourt here at Staples Center in
October that's off the rent ticket by ad
running the floor a little bit better
now the blonde with the basketball
attackers make yourself important in
other ways ah to step straight in see
nobody's boxing out can I only Anderson
just step straight to the free-throw
line and Caruso says look I can I'll
jump you it does what the Hoosiers said
Indiana University
Caruso to the master there's the Phantom
favor getting the extra cheers they love
him here in Los Angeles got a hand on it
now Caruso runs a break
[Applause]
[Music]
flying high for the rebound
over Howard hard flyby those hops right
there that's all ball baby
[Applause]
Alonzo ball gets the LeBron James to get
that layup ball turns it over collision
was teammate why wouldn't a right here
Giarrusso able to get himself inside the
lane and show off some of that athletic
ability more important absorb the con
comes out
JaVale nearly had it taken by Moran
kicks it over to Anderson
[Applause]
Rousseau night stake drives inside banks
at all from alex caruso aggressive mood
to the bucket what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content